I grew up in a family where we kind of
understood the business you know my dad
he didn't when he first started you know
he had no idea where to go or what to do
or how to even have people listen to
your music when I wanted to make this my
life when I want to be an entertainer my
family kind of okay knew this is how you
get started
I think we're really lucky to have such
a wide reach through the internet and
being able to like share our music not
having to wait for a label or for a
radio you can just put it out I tried to
stress this to the artist when I was min
touring to kind of show people different
ways to get their music out so I think
that's important get more power I think
it's gonna be very cool to have two
female coaches especially because as
much as the world likes to make this
girl catfight scenario we're so not
those girls that's actually Blake and
Adam who are more of those girls I'm a
little bit competitive Alicia and I are
new we're coming fresh into this I think
a main advantage I have of them I've
never pressed that button really in that
moment and they press this button so
many times so bad I feel flowers on the
inside I wanted to be on the voice as a
coach after I mentored last time I think
because everything that I like to do in
my life is it has to be real it has to
be authentic as to be genuine sitting
and watching people singing and helping
people make music it's what I would do
every day